hey I was going bros my name is
PewDiePie are you ready to explore
this creepiest websites ever
how creepy can't maybe let's be honest
here I've done some extensive research
to find the creepiest website on the
Internet
I basically just took three top 10 list
and ripped them all off which I'm sure
is what everyone else is doing first
website is called plane crash infocomm
and it basically has transcripts of the
last words from the cockpit recordings
of planes that crashed damn it Robert
said we're going to crash this can't be
happening and then Bannen was like but
what's happening
[Music]
staggering beauty calm I've seen this
one if you have the just warning for
flashing images but honestly how [ __ ]
bad is
[Music]
oh this one oh my god gross do you
remember this [ __ ] okay if you don't
know this I'm gonna read it anyway I
won't be scared of it cuz I know what's
gonna happen
bong Chun Doong goes it's [ __ ]
awesome this is one of the first horror
videos I did the stories based on true
eyewitness accounts it was at around
11:20 that night I was dragging myself
home exhausted after a tiring night
study sessions at school but there was
no one on the street which I thought was
strange I usually see a lot of people
even at nights is my apartment complex
is pretty big anyway feeling scared I
kept looking down on the ground walking
home
suddenly a shadow stretching towards me
caught my eyes although there wasn't
anyone around me I saw a woman walking
in front of me
but she looked a little strange I could
see that she looked crippled she was
limping and struggling to walk in front
of me since she was walking very slow I
soon caught up with her up close I was
able to see her even better
she was running dirty pink pajamas and
looked as if her joints in her body had
been twisted worse her hair was a mess
yeah that's that's always worse it's
sticking out everywhere it seems so
weird that they stopped walking I felt
like I shouldn't get any closer to her
nor did I have the guts to pass her by
oh my god
that [ __ ] scared me so [ __ ] much the
first time I did it I don't even know
why where's my baby my thoughts were
raising to her question oh my god
I don't even know what I was thinking
when I did that gives me the chills
thinking that moment
I answered pointing as far as I could
over there I could not think of anything
but to get to a place where there would
be people around she's not there I heard
her screaming from far away Oh God
okay so this website is called world's
birth and death simulated in real time
where basically you can simulate here
you see someone was born in China
Ukraine someone died [ __ ] oh my god is
so fast it's ridiculous there's
definitely more people getting born than
dying that's for sure I know actually
it's pretty oh my god stop living
oh my god what is this universe people
dot-org someday you will return home to
heaven
alright alright do you know what
selfless love is no okay
so they made a translation here for all
the people and like each other love each
other be nice to each other and [ __ ]
oh my god it's it's an Asian Swedish man
with epic hair we love you and help you
a star Sharon the lizards from hell
have kept you and will make you slaves
oh [ __ ] forgot I know that [ __ ]
those damn lizards
here's a website called occult Gamescom
which has a deaf calculator we're all
gonna die but when we'll see about that
and all right well I'm 25 25 mm I'm I'm
a main [ __ ]
male I am 180 I will die of a heart
attack that makes sense
well [ __ ] you to really really get to
your real life death date all right what
do we get what do we get
[ __ ] you really
really
ah angelfire calm that's how you know
it's legit this website tells me how to
summon Satan I write I write I write I
don't understand he's right here hey why
would i summon him again look at him
he's evil he pretends to be cute so he
can eat your face be scared aren't you
scared
this website is called gab rocked
tampons de it is it is a website that
sells used hi friends hope you enjoyed
this video if you did now's a great time
to leave a like I appreciate your
support it really helps out a lot
leave a comment about how to support the
spookiest experience you've seen on the
web now let's see bros in the next one
as always stay awesome what is happening
always putting up a jar